Few child actors have had a life story as
redemptive as iCarly's Jennette McCurdy. Though
her TV days are over, her life was forever changed
by the show — for better or sometimes worse.
Becoming a child star was never an aspiration
for Jennette McCurdy, but rather for her mother,
Debra. McCurdy alleged that it was her mom
who had wanted to become an actor. But when
those dreams didn't happen, Debra relentlessly
pursued that dream with her daughter. McCurdy's
childhood home life was also troubled. She
was homeschooled in a religious household,
her parents constantly fought and
her mother was a compulsive hoarder.
McCurdy said that most of the obsessive behavior
was attributed to her mother's health at the time.
In Jennette's infancy, her mother was diagnosed
with breast cancer. The actor said that her mother
began living vicariously through her and sent
McCurdy into the world of child acting. Debra also
routinely examined her daughter's body for signs
of cancer, among other troubling behaviors that
deeply traumatized McCurdy. It became difficult
for the Nickelodeon star to challenge her mother's
authority, as she would often remind McCurdy how
lucky she was for her early success on iCarly.
In her memoir, I’m Glad My Mom Died, McCurdy
writes that Debra would constantly tell her,
"Everyone wants what you have."
The pressure on Jennette McCurdy only got worse
the more successful iCarly became. Desperate
to keep up appearances on television, McCurdy's
mother taught her to develop an eating disorder
when she was only eleven years old. As
McCurdy later recounted in a Red Table
Talk with Jada Pinkett-Smith, her mom was the
one who encouraged her to restrict calories.
"We were just in the disease, in the
sickness. But there was a connection
that the sickness created that I, of
course, couldn't see at the time."
McCurdy's struggles with anorexia and
bulimia followed her into iCarly and
beyond. She was limiting herself to under 1,000
calories a day in an attempt to make her mom
proud. Even after the death of McCurdy's
mother, the eating disorder grew worse,
with the actor at one point collapsing
in co-star Miranda Cosgrove's bathroom.
Many child stars from Disney Channel
and Nickelodeon have attempted music
careers after the success of stars Selena
Gomez and Miley Cyrus. In her 2022 memoir,
I'm Glad My Mom Died, McCurdy revealed that when
iCarly was shut down due to the 2007 WGA Strike,
her mother pushed her into pursuing country music.
In 2009, she signed a record deal with Capitol
Records, turning down an offer from Taylor
Swift's then-home label Big Machine Records.
After releasing several singles and EPs, McCurdy
released her debut self-titled album in 2012. But
McCurdy's music career didn't last long,
as the Nickelodeon star ended up leaving
Capitol Records because of a commitment to
her new iCarly spin-off show, Sam & Cat.
McCurdy expressed regret over her country
music days in her memoir, though the brief
stint offered one huge shift in her life. Debra's
cancer returned and McCurdy was able to go on tour
without her. It was the first time the two were
separated since McCurdy was a young child. But her
solo excursion ended up creating more guilt
for McCurdy. She told The Guardian in 2022,
"God did it feel s---ty to feel relief
that I'm going to be away from my mom
for the first time, when my mom also was
just diagnosed with cancer and was dying."
Nickelodeon's iCarly ended its run in 2012,
though Jennette McCurdy didn't stray far from
the network in its immediate aftermath.
In 2013, the actor starred in a spin-off
series with Ariana Grande, Sam & Cat. When
McCurdy initially signed onto the show,
she was under the impression that it
was meant to be a solo series for her
character, Sam Puckett. Nickelodeon instead
re-developed it to include Grande's character.
While filming Sam & Cat, things started to spin
out of Jennette McCurdy's favor at the network.
She revealed in her memoir that Grande was
consistently given preferential treatment on the
program, missing entire weeks to pursue her music
career. McCurdy was forced to turn down several
film offers due to her contractual obligations
to Sam & Cat, a standard Grande was not held to.
McCurdy has since softened towards Grande
in recent years. She told Vogue in 2022,
"I'm able to look back on it and just
see it as the comedy gold that it is,
to be on set at 21, where you're just the most
susceptible to jealousy and comparison that
you can possibly be, and I'm there across
from a burgeoning pop star of the day."
"Oh! aahh, ah Oh.”
“Is it that bad?”
“Nah, you barely notice it."
A good portion of Jennette McCurdy's memoir,
I'm Glad My Mom Died, recounts her experiences
with The Creator, a pseudonym for iCarly and
Sam & Cat creator Dan Schneider. Schneider's
behavior was common knowledge by the time
of the book's release; Nickelodeon severed
ties with him in 2018, and he has since been
accused of verbal abuse and sexual misconduct.
McCurdy's memoir only added fuel to the fire.
She claimed that he intimidated her into
underage drinking, among other inappropriate
actions he committed towards her. She wrote,
"The Creator is doing the thing that I've
heard from my co-stars he does with every new
star of a show that he's making — he takes you
under his wing. You're his favorite. For now."
McCurdy began to rely heavily
on alcohol due to the stress and
abuse she was facing. She opened
up about her relationship with
alcohol for the first time in a 2020
episode of her podcast, Empty Inside.
As if the treatment Jennette McCurdy
faced from Nickelodeon on iCarly and
Sam & Cat wasn't enough, the actor was also
limited in her opportunities outside of the
network. Aside from having to turn down movie
offers due to Nickelodeon-related commitments,
McCurdy instead began making appearances
in similar projects on Nickelodeon.
Her guest spots on other popular Nickelodeon shows
included True Jackson, VP, and Victorious. While
her frequent appearances got her nominations at
the Teen Choice Awards and Kids' Choice Awards,
there was little career benefit the older she got.
It wasn't until after iCarly and Sam & Cat were
over that McCurdy branched out to more serious
roles. She appeared in the 2016 thriller Pet,
and most notably on the Netflix drama Between,
in which she starred in for two seasons.
In 2018, she made her directorial
debut with a short film, Kenny,
which premiered on YouTube's Short
of the Week. McCurdy was especially
proud of the project, having assembled
an all-female crew to help her make it.
McCurdy didn't have the benefit of
leaving Nickelodeon on good terms.
She stated in her memoir that the network
offered her $300,000 to stay quiet about
her experiences with Dan Schnider. Though
she ultimately turned the hush money down,
she briefly regretted the decision. These
days she's proud that she chose the path
of morality rather than caving to
the network that exploited her.
The death of Jennette McCurdy's mother Debra was
a pivotal moment in the young actor's life. Her
mother died in 2013, just three years after
receiving word that her cancer had returned,
when McCurdy was only 21 years old. Even without
the monumental figure in her life controlling
her every decision, it took years before
McCurdy could reconcile with the damage done.
McCurdy believes the kind of healing she
was able to do wouldn't be possible with
her mother still alive, stating that therapy
wasn't an option at the time. Even when she
finally started to seek help, it was a
long road to figure out how she really
felt. She recounted on The View that it was
tough going to the first therapist she saw.
"She said, 'You know, what you're
describing is abuse,' and I left.
I quit therapy. I couldn't tolerate the
idea, the notion that my mom was abusive."
McCurdy takes great pride in her ongoing mental
health journey, which she credits to unpacking
years of emotional and psychological
abuse at the hands of her mother.
In 2014, Sam & Cat was canceled after one season,
ending Jennette McCurdy's seven-year tenure on
Nickelodeon. A lifetime's worth of trauma
had occurred to the actor during that time,
but within a year she would make the first steps
towards shaping the rest of her career. McCurdy
began with creating, writing, and starring
in her own web series, What's Next For Sarah?
The autobiographical four-episode
show finds McCurdy playing Sarah,
whose hit tween TV show is canceled, throwing her
life in disarray as she tries to figure out what
to do next. The cast of What's Next For Sarah?
starred many Nickelodeon friends of McCurdy's,
including Mary Scheer, Shayne
Topp, and Danielle Morrow.
The show was McCurdy's first opportunity to
grapple with what her career in entertainment
has meant on her own terms. She's continued to
write and create art about what's happened to her,
while simultaneously pursuing a career that has
kept her far away from her Nickelodeon past.
There are one too many stories in
Hollywood of child actors being
taken advantage of by the adults in
their lives. McCurdy was no different,
given the extreme control exerted on
her life and career by her mother. While
McCurdy's acting success was a fulfillment
of her mom's lifelong dream to be a star,
there was also a practical purpose for it.
Through her acting gigs, Jennette became
the breadwinner of her family, supporting her
parents, grandparents and three older brothers.
But McCurdy didn't receive any of the money she
earned working as an actor. Her Coogan Account,
which is meant to shave off 15% of the salary
a child actor makes into a savings account,
was never properly filed. As a result,
McCurdy is unaware of what happened to
all of the money or where it went, but it's
believed to have been stolen by her mom.
McCurdy's hard work paid off in other regards
later in life. In 2022, she released her New York
Times Best Selling memoir all about the abuse she
suffered from her mother. McCurdy confirmed that
her older brothers were in favor of her decision
to speak out. She told The Hollywood Reporter,
"My brothers have been so supportive,
so understanding. They get
the title, to put it simply."
In 2020, McCurdy debuted her first one-woman
show, I'm Glad My Mom Died, which was her most
vulnerable work to date. She was initially
hesitant about performing the show herself,
though she eventually realized that only she
could tell her own story. The stage show ran
only for a few months at the start of 2020 before
the COVID-19 pandemic shut down live theater.
During the pandemic, McCurdy continued the
conversations about her past on her podcast
series, Empty Inside. With guests like Anna Faris,
Mike Birbiglia, and Daniel Sloss, she opened up
about her mom, her relationship with alcohol,
and her career. After reviving the one-woman show
in 2021, she turned her story into a memoir in
2022. I'm Glad My Mom Died sparked lots of media
attention as she came forward about the abuse she
suffered from both her mother and Nickelodeon.
"I think that anything worth saying is
probably going to be divisive. I think
if it's not divisive, it's probably, there's
probably no new conversation to be had there."
The book almost immediately sold out on
online retailers and remained at number
one on The New York Times bestseller
list for eight weeks. McCurdy has since
signed a new deal to write books for Penguin
Random House. She told The New York Times:
"Felt like finally I'm saying my words and
saying things I want to be saying. I'm myself."
McCurdy's life has been quite the rollercoaster
ever since she was first cast on iCarly in 2007.
Though she's been through a lot of unimaginable
tragedy and harrowing trauma, McCurdy has come out
on the other side stronger and braver. In 2021,
Paramount+ made the decision to reboot iCarly,
bringing back Miranda Cosgrove, Nathan
Kress, and Jerry Trainor to re-inhabit
the characters they had last played in
2012. But McCurdy said no thank you.
She described in her memoir that Cosgrove
contacted her personally to invite her to reprise
the role of Sam Puckett. Despite Cosgrove's
encouragement, McCurdy refused to return,
not wanting to retread the experience that
caused her so much pain throughout her life.
Nathan Kress later addressed McCurdy's absence
on his own podcast, RadioActive Dads, saying:
"I think it's just a personal decision and
where she's at and what she wants to do."
McCurdy has stated that she
doesn't miss the experience
of being on iCarly one bit. She knows
she's plenty busy with her book deals,
her new podcast Hard Feelings, and
her plans for writing and directing.
If you or anyone you know may be the
victim of child abuse or sexual assault,
contact the relevant resources below: